>> Tucker: LEFT CLAIMS IT
OPPOSES RACISM.
PROJECTING.
WHAT THEY SAY YOU ARE DOING
THEY ARE DOING.
AND CONSTANTLY FOMENTING
RACIAL HATRED.
THEY DO IT CONSTANTLY
PUBLISHING FAKE HATE CRIMES
OR INSTATING RACIAL QUOTA
SYSTEMS AND BRINGING BACK
SEGREGATION.
MINDLESS COVERAGE OF NEWS
STORIES.
THIS HEADLINE RAN IN THE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
QUOTING NOW.
WHITES ARE MAINLY TO BLAME
FOR AIR POLLUTION BUT BLACKS
AND HISPANICS BEAR THE
BURDEN SAYS A NEW STUDY.
IT'S TOO FUNNY.
LET'S JUST BE CLEAR THOUGH.
TAKE THREE STEPS BACK THIS
WAS DESIGNED TO ATTACK AN
ENTIRE GROUP BASED SOLELY ON
SKIN COLOR.
THE HEADLINE THE LEADING
PARAGRAPHS ARE ALL MEANT TO
ATTACK THIS ENEMY RACIAL
GROUP IN OUR MIDST AND IMPLY
THEY ARE RACIST BY DOING
WHAT?
IT DOESN'T SAY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY ARE HURTING OTHER
PEOPLE THIS ARTICLE DOESN'T
SEEK TO HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THEY COULD TALK ABOUT AIR
POLLUTION LEVELS.
BY THE ZAY DECLINED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST FEW
DECADES BECAUSE THE
FACTORIES CLOSED.
COULD HAVE FOCUSED ON THE
EXTRA BECAUSE DRIVEN
POPULATION GROWTH OR PEOPLE
JETTING TO ATTEND CLIMATE
CONFERENCES BUT THEY DIDN'T.
JEFF BECAUSE ZOS WOULDN'T
LIKE THAT HE IS ONE OF THOSE